bienvenue pour ce casse-tête très rare
un peu à l'ancienne mais qui a l'air
super sympa c'est un casse tête il a été
fabriqué par jean-claude constantin ça
s'appelle la serna reebok c'est la
version deluxe ça représente un petit
peu une barre comme ça donne à lire
c'est très joli difficulté 6 sur 6 il y
en a on en trouve dans aucune boutique
il y en a seulement deux qui
s'enchaînaient insoluble le casse tête
dont celui que j'ai dans les mains donc
il y en a plus qu'un en fait et ya
jamais eu de vidéos sur le sujet on sait
par le fabricant parlant que de
constanta qu'il faut 150 mouvement
minimum pour le résoudre minimum ça
c'est si on se trompe dans rien donc ça
peut vite monter à mieux au mans oui
parce qu'on peut faire une fois mille
mouvement non on peut pas on peut faire
on peut faire une fois on peut ni le
foot mais vous ne vous rappelle pas des
petites vidéos genre des casse tête avec
elle j'ai passé 17 heures auxquelles
google quelle heure est il
c'est bien on a commencé à 9h à l'eau
tellement si c'était un feu très doux
bon j'espère que je n'aurai pour un peu
moins longtemps parce que 17 heures
petit lino chaîne de lapin parce que ça
suffit pour en faire un petit tour
d'horizon sur le côté on a ses petits
trucs qui tourne qui ont été pointés ou
vice et qui semble habiter simple
élément de déco de toute manière sur le
haut que je vous refais revoir dans
quelques secondes on voit bien que c'est
là où ça se joue à pas trop de
d'exploration de par quoi je commencerai
à la soul gouvernail
ouh là là on va dire que là on a le nord
le sud est on à l'est et l'ouest comme
ça 6 te demandent eux en degrés denis
sud-est en degré c'est combien
135° là allez y allez là haut et
nord-ouest
315,6 si je suis en train de faire route
vers l'ouest et je veux faire demi-tour
faut que je mette le cap à combien de
degrés non à 270 moins 180 puisque tu
veux faire demi-tour à la lega légal
également bon on voit que sous
gouvernail il y à des plaques comme ça
qui semble-t-il pour est un petit peu
peut-être bouger bon je vais voir
comment mais je pense que ça doit se
coulisser et là vous le voyez peut-être
pas très très bien je vais essayer de
vous le rapprocher au maximum donc là
voilà je vous montre là vous voyez il ya
des petits picots comme ça à l'intérieur
qui vont permettre de faire coulisser ou
pas les plaques et c'est là dessus que
je vais bosser le plus en fait c'est sûr
ok alors ça fait quand même tirer dessus
par mesure de sécurité celui-là il se
lève quand même sacrément bien il pas
plus mais autant les autres bougent pas
du tout je retiens ça ça peut être un
point bloquant pour plus tard mais lui
se lève un petit peu celui ci les
plaques est ce que je peux les tiré par
là avec là aussi un boîtier des pics
aussi de ce côté là c'est un délire cd
picot où des accrochages remarque je
sais pas encore non à lui sa bouche au
hockey lui clairement il bouge et on
voit le pico qui qui qui passe comme ça
par de la rainure et je pense qu'il va
falloir réussir à tout défaire tiens ça
me rappelle quand même vachement
excalibur ans n'a pas été une partie de
plaisir puisque je vous rappelle qu'on
l'a fait en trois fois ouais je suis un
peu speed presque je vais et je vais
essayer de letra garder parce que je
pense clairement que c'est le genre de
casse tête sur lesquels tu peux vite
passé cinq heures en vrai lui il a bougé
alors lui maintenant qu'il a bougé texte
veut en faire bouger d'autres en
fonction parce que je vois bien que le
pico il se met devant d'autres renner en
fait
eh ouais du coup ça me libère lui parce
que lui je pouvais pas mais en faisant
ça
moi j'ai fait bien de
se retirer lui et ça ça me permet
d'avoir lui donc peut-être que du coup
ça me permettrait d'avoir un qui en face
en fait ça se regarde un peu ce soir
pas forcément
alors que tout leur est dû commencer par
essayer les autres je veux le faire pas
mal comme ça avec mes doigts
là pour l'instant je joue un peu à
regarder un peu les implications que ça
peut avoir
ni par exemple de le repousser quand
même moi donc tu peux faire tac
je peux faire aussi tac le refermer si
je veux vous permet en le refermant
pouvoir bouger lui et après quand même
de retirer lui oui ok on voit qu'il se
passe des choses du coup ça m'a bloqué
lui maintenant je vais bloqué maintenant
que j'ai tiré lui
allez on continue
yahia qui vont bouger dans d'autres sens
encore avons eu notre lot célé d'accord
est-ce qu'ils n'avaient pas des parties
fixes en fait j'ai l'impression qu'elle
est partie mobile et des parties fixes
mais c'est peut-être une illusion que
j'ai c'est peut-être pas vraiment le cas
ça va être chaud moi je vous le dis ça
va être chaud des fois la voix je
commence déjà à le faire mais des fois
je vais être obligé de mettre ma grosse
tête là les gars je vois pas comment on
peut faire autrement peut-être pop bcsa
way
s'est fixé plus vite j'ai du mal à
comprendre s'il ya des trucs fixe ou pas
s'il faut je les sorte tous c'est à dire
que l'homme restent 3es que ça va être
une mince affaire un dé sortir c'est
drôle je peux ou pas ça c'est super
compliqué de savoir ce qui est bouge à
blue pas
en r je mets un peu ma tête là mais j'ai
besoin de voir ce qui se passe devant
là j'ai beaucoup de mal à différencier
ce qui fait partie des choses qui ne
peuvent pas bouger du type ça c'est tout
lâche qu'on pense vraiment qu'ils
peuvent pas bouger et des picots à
l'intérieur qui eux peuvent bouger non
ils peuvent pas bougé non plus wen en
voilà parce que les picots ils sont un
peu et on peut les bouger mais on peut
pas les bouger milf ont peu une fois
quelqu'un avait bougé journée s'était
pas elles ne peuvent pas bouger le pico
dedans mais ils servent quand même de
guide à mes rainures l'a clairement ça
veut dire que lui pourrait bouger
bouger
on va déjà l'impression que je suis très
vite bloqué au début je me disais c c il
faut sortir les six ailettes et la boîte
va se relever mais je crois pas en fait
est ce que si je tourne ça je peux
enlever
la le macchabée jamais vu walking dead
moi j'ai eu walking away ici en fait le
lay qu'il est il est vrai mythe les
malades on peut le dire une espèce
d'allergies aux jours de travail qui
fait que les les genre de week end cela
c'est bon on peut y aller et elle est
après des clubs où l'on reprend par
contre la maladie qu'il avait laissé le
jeudi jeudi midi quoi ça leur prend
[Musique]
donc je vous disais je pensais qu'il
fallait sortir les six années d'une part
je sais pas si c'est vraiment possible
mais d'autre part par rapport à certains
tracés celui-ci vous voyez un peu là je
vous faire voir lui vous voyez ce tracé
là ce tracé où qu'ils communiquent en
gros c'est sûr que je peux pas bouger la
planche parce que aléas les emprisonner
dans ces deux bitonio par contre je
pense que peut-être un moment donné je
pourrais tourner l'ensemble comme ça et
que ce gros pic lui suivre ce je ne sais
pas il ya un mouvement il ya un truc est
un secret que j'ai pas encore percé de
cette boîte et je pense que ça peut être
potentiellement sa voix rauque et je ne
pourrai pas puisque ça et c'est un bon
exemple
l'epic ok là dedans il a un tracé qui
lui permet de faire ça donc là on aurait
tendance à se dire de du coup je peux
pousser je peux pas pousser puisqu'elle
gros truc là ce n'est pas un truc encore
démence 1
à 6 et dément tu vas pas
mais en plus ils ont une autre but et
intérieure oh la vache
alors qu'en fait on joue contre ça ça
que là ça c'est celui qui sait
[Musique]
d'accord je suis en train de vous
refaire mais en fait au final bon ben on
va aller chercher du post its avait un
peu et master donc allez on en prend au
pif celui-ci lui je veux sortir il est
piqué ici et se quitte là n'y a pas de
problème en fait celui-ci pas de
problème non plus il a peut-être un
problème au dessus si nos problèmes au
dessus c'est que c'est lui et lui il
peut pas bouger parce que de vie comme
ça
[Musique]
les gens brun lui j'aimerais l'amener
par là ça c'est mon but actuel donc
verser 3 pén qu
il ya lui qui m'emmerde
je cherche à ce que lui
par là pourquoi le jeu peut pas parce
qu'il embellit départ lui est là
maintenant je peux donc ça c'est à dire
que je peux n'ont toujours pas pourquoi
ah ça c'est parce qu'on ne peut pas on a
pas mille feux
dans la gardien qui bloque la ligne
bleue
vous souhaite donc en dessous à est en
dessous ça bloque donc
voilà donc lui
là c'est c'est quand même la preuve que
je peux en repérer un voir les points de
blocage essayer de les débloquer mais
comme tout est intrigué des fois en
assurant que je revienne en arrière lui
maintenant c'est bon aussi
ok maintenant pour essayer de faire lui
ok puis de faire lui alors lui pourquoi
je peux pas donc là ce que je veux faire
c'est lui
mais lui il ya ça qui m'embête
donc là faudra que je repense à un
moment donné
à refaire lui parce que je vais le
toucher
comme ça ok ensuite il ya quoi de kilos
classé bon là c'est bon là j'en ai un
qui bloque c'est lui si je fais ça
de là ils auraient dû y aller
on cherche les points de blocage et de
son bon attend elle aussi gelé bouger ne
couvre que je remercie ça c'est ce que
je bouge qu'il faudra ressortir
trangères est finie donc la libéré deux
points de blocage en faisant ça ok
[Musique]
nous sommes donc
dans sa place nulle part alors là je
comprends que
là je comprends là je comprends
moi aussi encore je fais ça il veut pas
quand je fais ça il veut pourquoi
revenir vers
lui
après on peut quand même sortir parfois
c'était le plus important pour nos du
cause lui et du coup
de coude à une maman de plus fin
il me manque plus que celui ci donc
celui ci on va chercher maintenant le
point de blocage de celui ci
alors là ça bloque pas donc je vois bien
ensuite aussi on a d'autres ici ça
bloque pas mais tout va bien ça donne à
l'arrière et ici ça bloque donc il faut
le faire comme ça on va faire ça ok
bon on a atteint un premier stade c'est
le stade où j'ai réussi à tout sortir
est-ce que c'est suffisant
bon
vous voyez retenez quelque chose de la
vie c'est que il suffisait
d'utiliser des post-it arrière de
l'intérieur pour résoudre ce casse-tête
les casse-têtes exponentielle tu me
donnes des post-it de la rue
basse à cinquante nouveaux rondement
menée j'ai commencé il était 14h45 15h10
25 minutes 25 minutes franchement je
suis fier de moi après ça reste des
castes est très difficile parce que mine
de rien je commence vraiment à être
rodés à ce casse-tête m mouvement
exponentielle je prends des notes je me
régale ici tout le monde sait cela va si
sûr si tu sais pas si ça les vaut c'est
déjà pas mal voici c'est déjà bien bon
allez un casse tête bien résolue c'est
un casse tête car hormis donc on est
reparti ab je vous faire voir aussi un
petit peu mieux là du coup
wilbert
le box qu'elle est bien belle
composé de six élèves a sorti dans un
environnement de bois luxieux chez de
petits
les tuyaux compliqué enlever sa
difficulté de 6 sur 650 mouvements ont
été trouvés par alpha mos of abu en
moins de 25 minutes maintenant
arrivera-t-il à la romaine à la refermer
vous allez le savoir tout
[Musique]
et du coup pour le 4 il faut que je
ressorte l'e3 donc il faut que je passe
tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac
a gelé tac tac tac
tox c'est bon et tac tac tac
oui l'élite et avec la logique pas en
faisant n'importe quoi je suis très
content cast est phénoménal il est
génial c'est vraiment le genre de type
de casse tête que j'adore que
jean-claude constantin s'est très bien
réalisé j'ai adoré ça jadwa lessard
merci beaucoup merci à vous qui regardez
la vidéo pensez à vous abonner pour voir
les beaux gasté qui arrive pensez-y
activer la cloche pour voir les vidéos
qui sortent ta bonnacois des minables
mais est-ce que tu serais pas abonnés à
la vie tout simplement il faut pas
oublier ça en parlant de pas oublié je
vous rappelle que mon nouveau livre est
sorti c'est tous les trucs que je sais
faire par rapport à la mémoire et que je
vous retransmet voilà je le fais très
rapidement très clairement la promo mais
liens et dans la description je pense
vraiment que ça peut vous être utile
prenez bien soin de vous prenez soin de
vous prenez soin de moi aussi ça me fera
plaisir à très bientôt cha